en direct françois constanty costantini
géopolitologue bonjour à vous merci
d'avoir accepté cette interview sur rtl
france l'union européenne renouvelle ses
sanctions vis-à-vis de la corée du nord
et kim jong-un a pour sa part réaffirmé
qu'il poursuit le développement de son
programme nucléaire selon vous pourquoi
l'union européenne elle semble ne pas
avoir tenté un dialogue avec pyongyang
mais d'une façon générale l'union
européenne n'a pas une prise directe sur
le dossier nord-coréen
il faut rappeler d'abord que c'est un
dossier qui étrangle est entre les mains
du conseil de sécurité des nations unies
qui a pour bras en quelque sorte avec
ces exécutifs exécutoire l'agencé
internationale de l'énergie atomique
bien même si celle ci en ce moment ne
peut pas se rendre se rendre sur place
la l'union européenne rend incertain de
sanctions qui sont des sanctions
symboliques et touche en effet comme
vous l'avez dit cinquante-sept personnes
membres du régime nord-coréen
elle concerne le gel de leurs avoirs
détenus dans des établissements
financiers dans des pays membres de
l'union européenne
mais à vrai dire l'union européenne ne
décide pas de dialogue dit alors il ya
c'est vrai des structures de dialogue
entre l'union européenne et la corée du
nord vous avez notamment à une
délégation union européenne et pour
l'ensemble de la péninsule péninsule
corénne il n'y a pas à proprement parler
de structures de dialogue direct entre
l'union européenne et la corée du nord
qui a été établi pour nazon ses clients
européenne a également du mal à
s'imposer sur ce dossier on sait d'une
part récemment que le président trump a
décidé d'ouvrir un canal direct avec kim
jong hoon avec les sommets qui ont eu
lieu notamment à singapour et au vietnam
et puis que de façon plus anciennes plus
traditionnel la russie d'une part et la
chine d'autre part ont un lien direct
avec le régime nord-coréen
alors il n'y a qu' il ya aussi cette
déclaration de kim jong-un notre
sécurité nationale et notre avenir
seront assurés
pour l'éternité c'est un discours qui a
été prononcé à l'occasion du 67e
anniversaire de l'armistice de la guerre
de corée
ce mardi comment interpréter ces propos
est-ce que c'est un avertissement aux
occidentaux et à leurs alliés asiatiques
là ce nom c'est ce propos est à relier
directement la stratégie nucléaire du
régime nord-coréen qui est en fait une
stratégie de sanctuary station du régime
en effet c'est ce qu'il atteigne
dissuasion du faible au fort mais plus
que là il s'agit en effet pour le régime
de kim jong hoon de pérenniser son
régime et de le faire justement parle
l'accès total par la maîtrise d'une part
du feu nucléaire et par la maîtrise
également dû du chemin balistique de
l'armé nucléaire de sanctuariser son
régime on sait très bien quand même que
le autour de lui la chine la russie les
états-unis ont quand même les niveaux 10
faisons du nucléaire bien bien plus
important mais néanmoins la possession
d'armes nucléaires pour la corée du nord
lui ouvre en effet toute possibilité de
pérenniser son régime et on l'a vu
notamment avec les sommets d'amis 18,5
kim jong-hun que c'était ce que voulait
le régime nord-coréen
alors justement brièvement que cette
onde ses 57 personnes et ses neuf
entités sanctionnées par l'union
européenne en raison de leur complicité
supposée avec le programme nucléaire
nord-coréen expo non c'est un peu plus
alors vraisemblablement un les
informations qu'on aurait ce qu'il
s'agirait de potentats civils et
militaires également du régime
nord-coréen ses airs de l'entourage de
kim jong hoon lui-même est également de
personnes venant du complexe militaro
industriel qui aurait une partie
prenante essentiel dans la structuration
du du programme nucléaire nord-coréen
alors on a ces sanctions européennes qui
s'ajoute aussi à celle de l'onu on
al'impression pourtant qu'elles ont pas
forcément en effet sur le dirigeant
nord-coréen pourquoi selon vous parce
que les sanctions pour moment le saut
que des sanctions disons
économique économique financière on n'a
jamais vu en effet des sanctions qui
frappent des dirigeants politiques
fussent s'agit style même des des
dirigeants principaux s'avérer des plus
efficaces et sanctions sont symboliques
elles vivent des visas circonscrit en
quelque sorte à tracer en quelque sorte
un cercle étanche entre ces dirigeants
là et la communauté internationale des
sanctions efficaces tiendrait d'une
pareille freight et des sanctions
retient d'ailleurs toute la communauté
internationale espère que les sanctions
le lui s'impose si les états unis mais
surtout la chine et la russie y étaient
partie prenante et on sait que là il ya
une divergence non pas pour empêcher la
corée du nord d'accéder à l'armé
nucléaire qui semble l'intérêt de tous
mais sur les stratégies notamment les
les intérêts divergents des uns et des
autres qui annihile quelque peu toute
chance défi de de mise en place de
sanctions efficaces françois constantini
merci je rappelle que vous êtes
géopolitologue merci d'avoir répondu à
nos questions